You see it on some jewelry in stores
now. They they used to call it the the
evil eye
symbol. So it's it's blue and
then it's got a white circle and then in
the middle of it it's got a black
circle. Right? many of us, you know,
look, when you save up in where I grew
up, you you save up for a bus or you
save up for a car to work on a taxi,
you've been saving for 10, 15, 20 years,
right? And now you finally got it.
You're going to love this thing with all
that you got. And this thing is your
bread and butter. And so people are
prone to try to hold on and latch on
to superstitions to try to protect their
investment. And so in taxis and buses
and places of business, they will
hang this this they even have it on
girls and women's jewelry or have it
on there. And this is supposed to
protect you from evil eye, right? This
is whenever someone comes by and they
have evil eye, it's going to it's going
to protect them. It's going to shut it
down, right? It's going to stop the evil
eye. Why? Because, you know, in
Chinese culture, they have a small kind
of pentagon that they put a smaller
mirror in and they'll put this up
outside the house or in their vehicles
or in their place of business. And this
is supposed to reflect away and deflect
you know demons and and so forth. All
of this is a type of what type of shirk.
These are land mines that are in our
homes waiting to claim parts of our dean
and waiting to claim our relationship
or aspects of our relationship with
Allah on the day of judgment. We will
continue this inshall next week.
Subhan Allah.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala mentions in
these verses.
He says
in the verse of
so remember me and I in turn shall
remember you all
and make mention of me and I in return
shall make mention of you all.
In another verse,
he proclaims
that your Lord has said,
"Call upon me and I shall respond.
Worship me and I shall reciprocate with
reward."
And
says in another verse
speaking to the prophets
and if my servants ask you about me
that I am near meaning inform them that
I am near. I am saying that I am here. I
respond
to those who call upon me and reach out
to me.
And so let them in turn respond to my
call and believe in me in order that
they may obtain enlightenment and
guidance. What do we understand from
these verses? And there are many verses
in the Quran similar in theme and
meaning to these verses.
What do we understand from this? We see
a pattern
that Allah
reminds us all
that he is not an absentee
God.
That our creator
is not a silent unresponsive
creator.
that when we reach out to the law, the
law in turn reciprocates and reaches out
in real time, not eventually,
not at the end of it all, not on the day
of judgment alone, but in real time.
When a person reaches out to Allah,
Allah reaches out to him.
When a person makes mention of the law,
the law makes mention of him. Listen to
these narrations.
be shut down.
He never meal
says that I am with my servant my slave
every time he makes mention of me and
his lips move with my remembrance.
And if he makes mention of me to himself
in himself, I will in turn make mention
of him in myself to myself.
And if he makes mention of me amongst a
group, I will make mention of him in
turn amongst a superior group.
The prophet
tells us in the narration of
Muslim that Allah himself has said
that
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us in
another
prophet tells us that Allah himself has
said that if my slave reaches out to me
a hand span I will reach out to him a
cubit in return
exponentially.
And if he reaches out to me a cubit, I
will reach out to him an arms length.
And if he comes to me walking, I shall
come to him running. Notice here of this
narration. I believe that many of us are
have heard this narration at least
before.
If we haven't committed it to memory, at
least we we have memorized and are
familiar with its meanings. The prophet
here tells us that Allah says that if my
servant reaches out to me a handspan,
I will reach out to him in turn a cubit.
This is twice as much. And if he reaches
out to me a cubit, I will reach out to
him in turn in response an arms length.
Meaning that whatever efforts the human
being puts in to reaching out to all
provided that that reaching out
is based and founded on
the law.
has to be found.
has instructed us so
we worship the Lord alone. We worship
him alone in the way that his prophet
has instructed us. There is no shame.
There is no innovation and those two
things come together. providing those
two conditions
are
when a person reaches out to a wall
figuratively obviously we are not
sitting around reaching up into the sky
figuratively when a person
reaches out to the wall they do a good
deed they do something to try and garner
attention from Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
when they reach out to Allah
exponentially
reaches out back.
Now when a person reaches out to Allah,
Allah
doubles that and reciprocates.
Why? Because one of the names of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala is a shepher.
What is a shepher? A shepherd
meaning the one who is worthy of all
gratitude and thanks
and she the one who thanks those who
from Japan.
Yeah.
Yes. For sure.
[Silence]
Allah subhanallah
is a meaning he is the one who is to be
the recipient. He is worthy of all
thanks and gratitude. And he is a
meaning he thanks and shows gratitude to
those who show him gratitude.
He reciprocates our efforts.
Not just a little bit, not just a little
more. He doesn't just reach out to us
equally.
Rather he subhanahala
dwells our efforts
because he is worthy of all things and
he subhanah
is worthy of all of the best
descriptions and attributes.
And so when a person reaches out to
Allah will double this and Allah will
respond. And no, that response is not
only on the day of judgment. That
response is not only when a person dies
and meets a law. No,
Allah will respond in real time
immediately.
Immediately.
Listen to this narration.
ation of the authority.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
Muslim the prophet
tells us that Allah has said I am
dividing prayer
into two equal halves between myself and
my servant
and for my servant what he asks of me.
And so when the servant says all praise
is due to Allah,
Allah will respond,
my servant has praised me.
And when the servant says,
Allah will respond, "My servant has
double down on his praise of me."
And when the servant
recites
the only being, Allah will say, "My
servant has proclaimed my greatness."
And when the servant recites,
Allah responds,
"This is between me and my servant, and
for my servant what he asks."
And then when the servant recites
to the end of the chapter,
Allah says, "This is for my servant and
for he what he has asked of me." What do
we notice here in this narration? We
notice that even between verses
when a person stands in and recites
Allah's words that immediately
Allah is interacting with the person in
real time immediately. And this is one
of the things that many of us
do not want.
One of the things that does to try to
weaken our resolve, to try to weaken and
slow our pace to Allah
is that we feel we are sometimes
worshiping and unresponsive
creator.
that a person feels that he has
prayed and asked and does and Allah does
not respond.
This couldn't be further from the truth.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala does not let a
single word a single utterance
even a thought of the remembrance of
Allah in the heart unspoken Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala reciprocates
immediately
immediately in real time he reciprocates
he responds right away
but the problem is is not that a
is an absentee God or that love does not
respond. That's not the issue.
The issue is that he does not respond in
the way that you
expect him to. That's the issue. You
want to know and learn how responds, you
read the Quran and you only expect what
Allah has promised you in the Quran.
You learn to pick up on the responses of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Not a single word,
not a single deed, no matter how slight,
no matter how obscure,
as long as it is done with the intent of
worshiping Allah, with the intent of
pleasing Allah, Allah will respond
immediately.
Allah will respond. Allah subhanahu
wa tala even responds to
disbelievers when they are in a jail and
they call to him. He still responds to
them.
The prophets
instruction
Yes.
I am the only sub.
The prophet
said there is no one more patient
on the terrible alarm or the the the
annoyances of what he hears from his
servants towards him. They ascribe to
him a child and they worship other than
Allah and he continues to grant them
ease. He continues to grant them and
feed them and sustain them and protect
them. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala he's not
petty a human being. He does not
have a vendetta against you. Your pain
is not special. We are all in pain at
times. We are all existing
in the mercy of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. But when you reach out to Allah,
when you remember Allah, when you thank
Allah, Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
responds. He responds every single time.
And he will reward you on the day of
judgment.
and he will respond exponentially and
twice
because you could never
be more merciful than Allah. You could
never be more diligent than Allah. You
could never be more loyal than Allah.
Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala responds.
The problem is many of us have not
learned how to observe those responses.
Some of the opinions of the online
commented that he will pick up
all a sin that he has committed in the
attitude of his spouse or even sometimes
in the attitude of his lifestyle
that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is
constantly
constantly interacting responding Even
when you stand to rec
you are speaking to Allah and he's
speaking right back to you. You are
speaking to Allah and he is speaking
right back to you.
The prophet
said that when a person stands for Allah
fixes his face to the face of his
servant to his right and he continues to
look back at his servant not looking
away until his servant looks away.
What more do you want? How much more can
we ask for Allah
not only responds but responds
exponentially and reciprocates every
minor effort?
And so how does a person build a
relationship with Allah? How does a
person reach out to Allah? How does a
person observe the responses of Allah?
This is not something you just know.
It's not something you decide. All those
responses are not going to be based on
what you expect. You have to read the
Quran. You have to acquaint yourself
with the law. You have to read the
prophets of the lawn.
You have to acquaint yourself with the
law's responses.
And then you will start to see them
everywhere and all around you.
Because our Lord is not absent. He is
always there, always responding at every
moment and he is at every turn and
junction.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
[Arabic recitation]
I'm not how many of us have done
something bad for instance
whatever it is and then later on that
day we hit our head or we trip or we get
into an accident or something bad
happens and immediately we say you know
what this is punishment for that thing I
did earlier today right this happens to
everyone many of us I experienced this.
You are going to do something that maybe
you shouldn't be doing or maybe you're
uncertain about and then some kind of
pain comes down the road and immediately
you think that's that's a punishment for
this that I did. Why don't we have that
same observation for the good things
that we do?
The answer is that it is so from a
regime that whispers these kinds of
things.
There's no there's no sunnah that if you
do something bad, you're going to hit
your head that day later or you're going
to hit your finger or you're going to
drop your keys or you're going to be
late to work or whatever it is that
people come up with. This is your
imagination mixed with the whispers of
Allah is ever slow to punishment and he
is immediate in reward. Allah will take
back his punishment. He will never take
back his reward.
Why are we not that sensitive to good?
I'll tell you why. Because the human
being is twice as sensitive to pain as
he is to pleasure.
That's why you ever notice that when you
see in the newspaper and the news that
a company tells you this product is
going to be discontinued and you got to
run out and go buy it real quick before
it goes. That's because you're afraid of
losing something. The pain of losing
something is twice as bad as the
pleasure of gaining it.
That's how we're wired. We are afraid of
pain.
This is not something that we learn from
the Quran and we are to think good
thoughts and make the best of it Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. Why is it that all
bad things we ascribe to Allah and then
good things we ascribe to other than
Allah? No, it is exactly the opposite.
It is exactly the opposite. Look and
become hyper sensitive to the good
things in your life. Day to day you will
lose count before the first hour of your
day.
Those
who are in nothing but fear and have and
nothing to hurt from their creator. We
have
so many more chances and are so much
more likely to find ourselves stumbling
into the graces of the world that we are
to be held to account and punish doesn't
mean
doesn't mean that
I
balance of justice is
that's not the case. However, Allah
doesn't have a feel against you. He
doesn't hate you. Who are you or me to
be this
is taking on as a particular
tells us.
He says what does the world want with
your punishment? What benefit does he
from your punishment if you are thankful
and believe in him?
[Arabic recitation]
stand shoulder to shoulder. Align your
shoulders and feet with the shoulders
and feet of your two neighbors. Use the
lines in the carpet as a guide, but
ultimately align your shoulders and your
feet with the shoulders and feet of your
two neighbors. Straightening the row and
maintaining the coherence of the row and
is part of and when one of us is out of
place, it affects the reward of all of
us in the prayer. You've worked this
hard to come all the way out here. Take
this time out of your day. Finish it.
Put the dots on the eyes and the
crosses across the te's. please
double check your phones. Make sure that
they are silent. Do not join a row until
the row ahead of you is completely
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]